all right let
us look at the strategic
problem of the fact that
if i if let's just start a video if i
have let's just use the colloquial
term if i have a fight
i'm going to have only two things i can
say about it
okay one
is that it's going to move
and two is anything can happen
okay this
is as much a strategic problem as it is
a tactical problem
as it is a mind problem
in the buddhist sense of the word
anything is a lot to deal with
okay what modern systems do
is they try to artificially get rid of
this fact
so you do boxing no kicks
you do a ground fighting no weapons
you see it goes like no strikes it goes
like that
kick only this target no friend coming
in from the flank
no weapons etc it actually isn't dealing
with anything
but the ancients dealt with anything
as a spiritual tradition this is why
buddha works
you are coming face to face with the
infinite
how do you deal with it
you have three ways
one is
a cultivated body mind
so this this will go to our um other
lecture
so this is your motion
your food ocean
[Music]
this is the unfettered mind the mind
that is not overwhelmed by anything
because it does not
see an infinite amount of things it sees
one thing
the second thing is
in aikido is this ikea adhesion
this allows me to have in here
i can deal with the infinite
and here i become connected
inseparable from the infinite
so i don't face the infinite in an
adversarial way
or tactically as a game of catch-up
or a game of prevention
the second you do something i'm already
touching you
whatever you're doing i not only know
what you're doing i am what you're doing
and then the third way is
that you're setting up dilemmas
meaning i am systematically
taking away your possibilities
and setting you up with probabilities
okay
so i take the infinite nature of this
but i make more things probable as i
make
less things probable i'm no longer
dealing with
possibility okay
so when he has
for example
let's take the bottom one the dilemma
where i take the
anything and i reduce it to
probabilities
okay so he goes to do at this point
you would ask what could he do
when you you would just run out of time
listen him but now
what can he do
not as many things because his
balance is being affected because
most of that anything requires
his equilibrium and so in your
aikido this is why you attack his
equilibrium
because you immediately get rid of a
whole bunch of stuff
okay so he's gonna do whatever
i'm here
taking his kazushi and now he has to
choose
i can tell or it feels like he wants to
do that punch
but he has to choose now through this
dilemma
does he risk losing more balance or
does he try to punch me okay now he's
not punching me
do you see
but at the same time let's just stick
with that one
he goes i set up the dilemma by taking
his balance
and here you can see i'm not blocking
his
punch i am not guessing he's
punching i just am connected to this arm
okay so when you see this it looks like
he's punching slow uh right
but if he goes he goes really fast
it doesn't matter i stick to the punch
the mechanics of the punch are not there
the distance the gap the inertia the
momentum
it's never there because i am not the
target i'm part of the punch
that's your ikea adhesion so wherever we
go
let's say he decides not to throw that
punch he goes for his base keep going
right and then i'm just passing that
adhesion
over and over and over again i'm not
guessing
for example oh when i when you do this
to someone's balance
he's going to want to brace himself i
don't i'm not guessing that
i'm just feeling that he goes to brace i
feel it i feel it i'm just feeling these
things
constantly because i'm one with them
and while i'm doing that i never let my
mind go
he's gonna punch keep going keep going
do something
he's gonna punch no that's not what
happens
i don't chase the infinite
manifestations
my mind is fluid he goes i'm staying
i'm staying i'm staying we're just stuck
the entire time
okay
otherwise you'll become overwhelmed by
the infinity
you can't stay up you can't stay up
okay